okay let's hear from some folks in the
audience taking
calls via discord at davidpakman.com
discord join the community on discord
it's free i think about um
11 000 people now on the discord maybe
approaching 12 000
it's a great thing all right let's see
what's on people's minds
starting with let's go to grayson from
seattle grayson from seattle you're on
the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
great
um so i was wondering what you think the
future holds
for conservative commentators like
stephen crowder or
centrist and i have centrist in quotes
uh commentators like tim poole
uh brother especially was was pretty
radio silent
and um i was just wondering what kind of
content can they even produce now that
all their darlings
are terrorist inciters or sympathizers
wait so you're saying crowder has been
radio silent i didn't know that yeah
after
january 6th he was pretty silent like
like one or two
low effort tweets i think he started
doing his show
recently again i mean i don't like
watching it so i haven't looked at it
too much but
i mean i just don't know what kind of
argument he has anymore you know
it's i i mean i know what the argument
will be and we're already
you all you have to do is look at fox
news and oan and newsmax to understand
that there is still a very much alive
uh radical rights sort of uh perspective
and it includes going back to all of the
tired old tropes uh laura ingram did it
on fox news i think it was monday night
where she did you know this segment
about the biden insurrection and he's
welcoming on dangerous undocumented
immigrants and
brown people and all this stuff and
here's the thing
that may be so tired and boring to you
and i who are now looking
to see what will joe biden get done and
can we start restoring the reputation of
the country
but you can do really well uh as an
individual show or channel with a tiny
slice of the american public because
there's 331 million people in the
country so i think that they're going to
do just fine i mean to people
to people like us who now we just laugh
when we see them go back to their same
talking points okay we're not in their
audience but i think they're going to do
fine
yeah fair enough i think you're right
and then i had a quick argentine lingo
question if you don't mind
oh sure of course so i've heard my
argentine friends say
boludo to each other right can i get
away with saying that
in a friendly way or is that a bit too
aggressive to say to my friend
i think it's fine i mean it's so it's
not you know it's not a thing where
you're just kind of saying kind of like
hey you prick
you know you're it's not uh it's not
racially discriminatory
it's not uh you're not picking on any
particular religion or anything like
that i think it's fine
and it'll show you to be sort of like an
insider to the lingo i think you're
you're fine with that
perfect well i think this might have
been a perfect call this was a perfect
phone call absolutely thank you uh
grayson from seattle
great to hear from you uh and hope to
hear from you again
one of our sponsors is privacy a free
service that protects your credit and
debit card i use privacy every time i
buy something online
i installed the app on my phone and the
privacy desktop browser extension
now when i pay for anything privacy
autofills a virtual
credit card number the money's taken out
of my bank account i don't have to give
out my real card number or banking info
to anyone
you can create and delete the virtual
cards anytime
i especially love it for free trials
because i can destroy the virtual card
number as soon as i give it to the
company and i know i won't be charged in
the future
privacy also has a feature called shared
cards
which makes it easy to split payments
with friends parents can manage a
virtual card for their kid
with spending limits businesses can
manage virtual cards
for employees to use for company
expenses there are premium plans
available but privacy's regular service
is totally free to use
and right now they'll give you five
dollars just for signing up when you go
to privacy.com
pacman the link is underneath this video